filipinos tuned in to president rodrigo
duterte's presumably
last state of the nation speech on
monday with critics looking for clues to
see whether he'll actually give up power
his term is supposed to wrap up next
year the populist leader has
chipped away at the country's democratic
institutions yet has maintained
tremendous support from the majority of
citizens
he has however vocal opponents
[Music]
these protesters can't wait to see the
back of their president
[Applause]
before rodrigo duterte's speech in
congress
demonstrators thronged the streets of
manila
calling for him to step down
beyond the police cordon duterte arrived
for his final state of the nation
address
for nearly three and a half hours the
president talked tough
renewing his often repeated threat to
kill drug dealers
those who destroy my country
i will kill you and those
who destroy the young people of
our country i will kill you
because i love my country
duterte's term and offers ends in june
next year
but his opponents fear that he will find
a way to hold on to power
the ruling party has already called for
him to stand as vice president
possibly with his daughter running to
succeed him
duterte is the one forcing us to protest
during the pandemic
duterte wants to stay in power for
another six years and i think
that is the single biggest threat to the
country right now he's staying in power
beyond 2022.
so he's the one pushing people to
protest his policies are pushing people
to protest
those policies include duterte's
notorious war on drugs
in which thousands have been killed
since he came to power in 2016
such as the scale of the purges that the
international criminal court is
considering investigating duterte
for crimes against humanity
the covet pandemic has also tested
duterte's presidency
lockdowns have plunged the philippines
into the worst recession since world war
ii and the government's vaccination
campaign has faced delays due to supply
problems
with just over five percent of filipinos
fully vaccinated
and the delta variant sending infection
numbers up once again
the pandemic is set to dominate
duterte's agenda
in the last year of his presidency
joining us is nicole corrado from the
center for deliberative democracy and
global governance at the university of
canberra nicole i think at the top of
everyone's mind
is duterte turning out of his presidency
but no one seems to believe he'll give
up power
what is the prospect he'll find a way to
stay on
well one possibility that he raised is
to run again
for vice president the philippines has
uh termix us or maximum terms for
presidency so he's finding a legal
loophole
to still remain in power without
violating the constitution
so if he is going to
do that what are we going to see in
terms of the durability of the
philippines democracy i mean we're three
decades
out since the people power revolution
that ended the marco's dictatorship in
1986.
yes and i think what's at stake here is
not just philippine democracy it's also
the strength of global institutions
that try to protect liberal democracy so
one reason why president duterte wants
to stay on in power is to make sure that
he has immunity
from the prosecution of the
international criminal court
so last december icc chief prosecutor
fatou bensouda said that the scale of
deaths in the philippines related to the
drug war
is proportionate to crimes against
humanity and obviously president duterte
is implicated here so it's not just the
philippines democracy that it's at stake
here
president duterte is testing the
boundary and the power
of global institutions that hold leaders
accountable around the world
you talk about global institutions but
i'm curious about the
domestic institutions uh how durable are
they
the different branches of the government
to ensure that despite
someone with autocratic tendencies like
duterte that
uh the philippines democracy can endure
so one of the concerning institutions
that's very much corroded in the duterte
administration
are the coercive apparatus particularly
the police
so we see a generation of new policemen
who basically have been trained in the
drug war of being able to kill
on citizens with impunity without due
process so that is definitely
worth monitoring there have also been
concerns that the supreme court has been
heavily politicized
and in the congress he holds a super
majority so what are we seeing here the
basic checks and balances
in the philippines has been corroded in
the duterte administration
and yet he still remains legitimate
because more than 90 percent of
filipinos
give him a high satisfaction rating so
it sounds like
what duterte said in his speech he
invoked his war on drugs which of course
has led to extrajudicial killings
and condemnation from human rights
groups
that people are still buying into his
talk and
and what i don't understand is the
pandemic seems to not have changed too
much of that there's still a lot of
support for him
yes although i do have to qualify that
so my research for the past
five years has been to understand the
kind of support that ordinary filipinos
give to president duterte
and i must say that it's not fanatical
support it's very much a conditional
support
so if you ask ordinary filipinos whether
in surveys or in
in-depth interviews a lot of them would
say that they expected more from the
government
but a lot of them also don't necessarily
blame president duterte for the
philippines condition
in relation to the pandemic a recent
survey actually found that ordinary
citizens
blame their fellow ordinary citizens who
are violating health protocols
so in a way it's kind of easy to
understand why the president still
maintains popularity
blame is not assigned to him but blame
is assigned to
fellow citizens which is the same logic
that we see when we think about the drug
war
when you ask ordinary filipinos about
the drug war
they would say actually yes i feel safer
in the streets now
but they also recognized that they or
their family members could be the next
victim
of violence or extrajudicial killings so
it's a bit more complicated than it's
typically portrayed by international
media
ordinary filipinos who support the
president are not are not fanatical
it's a product of weighing and different
considerations
uh that make them support the president
now we seem to see
a lot of countries in the region tilting
away from democracy
to autocracy thailand myanmar how
concerning
is all of that including of course the
philippines
and putting it all in context
yes it's definitely concerning the
philippines is one of asia's oldest
democracy
it has given itself pride by having some
of the freest media
around the world but what we are seeing
as part of the duterte legacy is the
encroachment of those freedoms so i
think the elections in 2022 will be a
big test
because either we see a restoration of
some form of trust for democracy
or we might see an authoritarian
consolidation
nicole corrado thank you so much for
joining us
my pleasure
you